very simple question i want blank to
sign with the blank red zone out good
friend of ours from across the pond
who's been asking questions for 10 years
now
he wants antonio brown to sign with the
patriots well he may be the only one who
wants that
because the patriots have made it clear
that that ship sailed the moment that
they signed him and then found out after
signing them that there was a looming
lawsuit for sexual assault and rape that
he knew about
that he and his agent at the time drew
rosenhaus didn't tell them about that
burned that bridge it was done and then
he filed a grievance against them to get
his money so
that's the last team other than maybe
the raiders at this point that would
sign antonio brown if he plays at all
miles i think it's going to be back to
the tampa bay buccaneers now now
can't rule out the seahawks because
russell wilson has wanted him in the
past can't rule out the packers because
maybe aaron rodgers wants him now but
wouldn't it be something if one of these
other great quarterbacks puts the screws
to their front offices to say hey let's
go in there and let's offer antonio
brown something other than whatever
minimum value contract the buccaneers
think they can get him with and maybe we
get a little bidding war for antonio
brown among great teams with great
quarterbacks who see the value in having
him around
well i if i'm a great quarterback i
think i'm just gonna have to give that
one up to tom brady because i think that
antonio brown should at least know by
now that his best spot is wherever tom
brady is so if tom brady decides all of
a sudden in a couple years you know i
want to go play somewhere else then
that's exactly where antonio brown
should be because antonio brown and tom
brady have figured it out you know for
whatever reason they work very well
together and i think that antonio brown
as long as he can stick with tom brady
that is exactly where he should be and
he should definitely not be back with
the patriots i mean you mentioned the
grievance and everything and everything
that they found out about him but then
he also had that uh got caught in the
parlor tweet about robert kraft so i
definitely even though he apologized for
that i can't see him ever going back to
new england and then let me just say
this as it relates to antonio brown
because i've tried to be and i never
know whether the right word is
sympathetic or empathetic i've just
tried to be understanding of his plight
given the possibility that the very bad
decisions he's made have in some way
been the product of some sort of mental
or behavioral health issue that needs to
be resolved through proper treatment
medication and you know we're all
responsible for our actions and i'm not
making excuses for him i'll say this
though if tom brady somehow has some
magical way to get through to antonio
brown and brown listens to him because
he respects him that undercuts the idea
that there's something wrong with him
and that there's some sort of a again i
don't want to say excuse but my point is
this to the extent that tom brady has
gotten this guy on the right path
it makes me think he's just a jerk
and there's just one person that he's
managed to find who he'll listen to
miles
you know what mike i can't disagree with
anything you just said especially as
somebody who covered the raiders in 2019
in that whole saga through training camp
through week one so yep
uh at gunk show west would like to see
kyler murray
sign with the oakland a's yes the
oakland a's if he gets traded to houston
for deshawn watson and that that's
something that kyler murray has
at his disposal that very few other nfl
players have the opportunity to go play
at a high level in another sport he'd
have to pay back about 11 million and
change 11.5 million if he would walk
away now from the nfl but uh yeah if
he'd get dumped on the texans and i like
the idea of desean watson to the
cardinals but if kyle doesn't want to
play for the texans he can go play for
the a's and uh i don't rule that out
until he's too old to play baseball i
don't rule out the possibility of
calamari doing that miles well hey i
mean he's going to be young enough to
play baseball maybe by the time he's
done playing football so he was wearing
the a's hat the other night or whatever
venue he was at and that kind of caused
a little bit of a stir i remember so
look if he wants to go play baseball
more power to him especially if he gets
traded to houston
you know jameis winston always kind of
had that on the radar screen the
buccaneers had concerns about him
ditching football for baseball but
that's the problem and you know nfl
coaches want players who are all in with
football and it's rare to find a guy
that's got a level of talent that is so
rare that that he could do both sports
or either sport and colin murray said
he'd love to be able to play both sports
it's kind of hard to do when you're a
quarterback though in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports